[Music]
what we chosen the mill is a
traditionally Gujarati mill okra is very
popular my customer load the okra in the
Prasad is a fasting selling this the key
to push out success is the way they
transform traditional family recipes
with a unique balance of tastes textures
and spices in India every two days lead
in okra and the doll and the rice for
the main course they're cooking aqua
curry said with a Gujarati dal soup rice
and writer who now starts by chopping an
onion and fine it with fenugreek seeds
and chopped garlic then Cal she adds
turmeric red chilli powder ground
coriander and tomatoes next the okra
sometimes called lady's fingers it's a
type of green bean
it's sticky inside if you dry them there
before it's better if you make press the
lipstick we to each other how she fries
it and adds it to the curry
next the lentil soup or dal lentil is
take time because we need to boil not
ready at least 15 minutes when the
lentils are ready manal liquid icism and
then add liquid ice tomatoes then the
prasad magic
turmeric red chilli powder jaggery and
finally coriander this is a very
balanced meal because okra it's not too
spicy curry that lentil soup it's very
creamy and rich and little bit of sweet
and tangy so flavor is balanced very
well finally banal price dried chilies
and asked cumin and then returns to the
DAO
[Music]
I'm just checking yeah he's done in
Indian cuisine is a not much going on in
a presentation so now I have to try with
harder if Gordon says we need Venus when
we survey the complex interplay of chase
works brilliantly in this dish creamy
crunchy cold spicy prasad are always
trying to elevate humble vegetables to
odd cuizeen what's really impressing me
today is how prasad are trying to keep
the soul of their homeland Gujarati
dishes but giving them a facelift for my
restaurant
[Music]
but a service ramps up even for shards
calm facade is beginning to crack food
is being spilled and they're starting to
get in each other's way
Oh manal it what's happening here I got
20 good luck
yeah away now the top is back on form
and holding it together in the dining
room we're in them flow now the food's
coming up isn't this good and it's been
received well Kapoor Shaad than enough
to convince my diners their main cause
is worthy of the final it's Cambrian
smart which I like I like this delicious
but will it be enough to impress my
demanding experts facades bindi how was
that aqua the tastes were really intense
very powerful and really expertly done
and done with ease you can tell the
person that cooked that they just do it
with ease it comes you know it's very
passion and it just it's really skillful
very first very hard to get okra tasting
delicious
it was great I just think they could
have lifted everything slightly one
level up